[Music]
hey everybody
a few of us who worked on this film
called soul wanted to
tell you a little bit about one of our
favorite scenes i'm pete doctor the
director
hi i'm dana murray the producer hey i'm
mike jones i'm one of the co-writers and
i'm ken powers the co-director at
co-writer
and uh the scene we want to talk about
is uh really the anchor of the whole
movie
for many of us we have these dreams and
aspirations in our lives and
deep down we think once we've achieved
these dreams our lives are somehow going
to be
complete all wrapped up in a nice bow
but more often
we find that hey we're still the same
and as great as this event was
somehow it didn't fix everything and
we're left wondering
well did i do something wrong what's
what's the right way what's life really
all about
so here after a lifetime of trying our
main character joe
finally has a chance to play with
legendary saxophonist dorothea williams
and
it is the night of his life
i think what a lot of people might not
realize is that obsession musicians
actually matched up to dorothea williams
band so your saxophone player
was a black woman the bass player was an
asian woman there was a brother
a young brother on the drums yeah and of
course john batiste on piano
but that was like a really cool touch to
be in that musical session and seeing
the
the people playing the live music
reflecting the characters on
stage it makes me
really want to go to a show i miss shows
it goes back to the inspirations for the
whole thing
and we were really struggling with ways
to express
her like we were thinking oh yeah
dorothea has been here before too
she's been through this and she's moved
past it and so
what advice is she going to give to him
in a sort of miles davis
enigmatic way yeah the butter notes yeah
herbie hancock told us at one point he
was playing and he was struggling
and miles said don't play the butter
notes
and he's like what what what does that
even mean
he wouldn't tell you what it meant it
was just up to you to figure it out
so we had one version where she just
said you know what
i had the best cup of coffee today
and walked away and it felt kind of
dismissive like she wasn't actually
listening to him
says the older fish that's what she in
right now
this says young fish this is water
what i want is the ocean that felt just
enough like okay i heard what you're
saying
and i'm answering you but you're gonna
have to think about this
dorothea totally knows what she's doing
yeah
i love that transition too i feel like
a lot of times when you're in your own
head and you're thinking about something
the world changes and you don't you just
stay
put and so that idea of the cross
dissolve matching to the subway
was meant to feel that that was largely
inspired by
trent and atticus trent specifically
mentioned that he really connected
with joe's story this idea that somehow
this accomplishment is going to fix
things it's going to make everything
make sense and put it in order and it
doesn't
and he had a very personal story of
having gone through that himself which
it actually really helped steer us
through the storytelling it was because
of that
that we put that scene with the subway
[Music]
in
we were looking for some way to express
the idea that joe
would discover in this moment that
the little things in his life that he
would have dismissed
or walked right past those are
important those are sacred we had this
idea that
he could remove the sheet music which
sort of represents the plan that joe
thought he had for his life and put
those objects down
in its place i had written
this near the uh death of my father
he had just passed away my father had
slowly
uh kind of faded away through dementia
and it was
memory and the retaining of those
memories was always really crucial to me
and
in our last interactions i brought i'd
bring a lot of photos to him and a lot
of items and
you would find those sparks and you
would see the
the life kind of come back in his eyes a
bit i i think it was really just a quick
step from that
into this movie i mean we're always
required to
bring our heart into this and man that
was right up front for me at that time
so we thought about 22 throughout this
adventure collecting all of these
objects that
meant something to her kind of like a
little kid would
my kids when i do their laundry the
stuff that they save throughout the day
and pick
up and it i just love that yeah so this
was a combination of trying to place
these
objects that 22 could collect during the
day and not make such a big deal out of
it the audience is like why is that
happening
that's going to be used later getting
this to work was so hard of course
because we also do that
transition where it starts with him
recalling 22's experiences
and then transition into him suddenly
remembering his own experiences and
those experiences he took for granted
when we were trying to create these
memories i remember we talked a lot
about
what are memories that would make us
feel warmth
inside that would make us feel loved and
comfortable and some of those memories
never changed
regb one of our story artists boarded
joe's feet in the sand
and i remember watching that going i can
feel that on my own feet
right at this moment
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you